today's topic you guys might be confused
by the title but i will explain
the reason why we haven't covered
palestine or haven't spoken about
palestine
is because i have nothing inside we
don't care
because we don't care i'm just kidding i
have nothing insightful to say about
palestine
so i don't want to talk about the
situation israel palestine because i
have nothing insightful to say
and if i have nothing insightful to say
i'ma just shut the [ __ ] up i'm not going
to do some random video for views but
since you guys have been harassing us
constantly flooding us
telling us if we don't do it we're bad
people if we don't blah blah blah this
or that
i'm gonna say this stop looking
to celebrities to speak on every
political issue you care about we're not
your mouthpiece one
and two we're not the right people to
speak about most of this [ __ ] neither
are most celebrities
they don't know [ __ ] all you're talking
about a dude who never graduated from
high school and another guy over here
who barely got his college education
okay and as far as like
did you what do you mean barely bro two
semesters
not even barely it's not like i didn't
even start you barely started
barely started that's better okay
finished
but i've been getting all this and
people were like why wouldn't you
educate yourself
because i don't want to why what did you
want to you don't care about kids dying
do you care about kids dying in myanmar
do you care about kids dying in tibet do
you care about kids dying in ukraine do
you care about kids dying in hong kong
do you care about kids dying in
venezuela colombia
ethiopia i didn't cover any of those but
most of y'all had nothing to say for a
lot of those issues right
but when it's something that touches you
or you're close to if i don't speak
about it i'm a trash person
yeah you could have this argument for
everything sudan cancer
obesity all this stuff i could clamor
here and if you don't talk about it
if you feel powerless because of this
issue
that's not me to bear the brunt of your
powerlessness it's not on me
to bear the brunt of your feeling of
inadequacy you lashing out at me
is unproductive it's not going to solve
these what else is unproductive
me trying to speak on something i have
no knowledge about and have very little
interest
oh maybe this is not pc enough are there
kids dying gabon's like
i'm not interested in talking about it
and guess what every human being has to
pick their battles
and this is yours and if it's yours
great if you want to be invested great
go ahead but don't come at me just
because i haven't said something and try
to infer something about my character
i don't go to everyone who didn't post
blm and be like you're trash or there's
your dad i don't go to everyone who
didn't support what was going on
within ethiopia right now go you're this
you're that but then you think you can
come and talk about someone else's
character because they didn't talk about
something that touches you
and for me the reason why i want to
bring this up is i think this goes back
to a larger issue
stop looking towards these celebrities
and empowering them when it comes to
public discourse the power lies in you
the individual people you guys should be
educating yourself you guys should be
creating movements you guys should be
creating boycotts doing that kind of
work
don't look towards those powerful folks
because the more power you give them the
more they can use that to [ __ ] you over
in the future
celebrities influencers whatever the
[ __ ] you want to call them okay you
should not be giving it to them
to speak on your issues to give power
to the things that you're going through
because if you constantly look to them
you are going to be disappointed so
often in your life and you're often
going to feel powerless
so go handle it go do what you got to do
all right a bunch of creators reached
out to me
people say talk about palestine most of
them have
zero education about geopol political
situations they have
zero idea of the west bank they can't
even find it on a map
but you want them to give their opinion
but what's the point of me giving an
unnuanced opinion on such a complex
issue
what's the point i add nothing to the
conversation and i don't make my viewers
any more informed now if you guys want
resources where you guys can go there's
a lot better youtube channels
to cover this kind of topics would you
talk about two guys who made a video
recently about dick jokes and [ __ ]
you know two guys going on a date with a
lesbian like
you're moving mad blood no no you're
moving mad
you gotta say it correctly moving mud
like a proper
batman the thing is this you're
ethiopian there's something that
happened in
ethiopia recently yep i mean still
happening
still happening to this and i'm haitian
something is happening right now in
haiti we didn't speak on that
sometimes there's nothing more that
we're gonna be able to
add i don't care if you say like yo talk
about palestine i don't care about that
that i don't care about that whenever
people come up to that but when it's you
start i'd be like yo
yo keep yo you you keep being you keep
being silenced about that and this and
that and you're trying to lecture me on
things that i do not talk about
is not understanding what we do here if
we're able to add to the conversation
we will and for anybody else
tate should take that advice if i can't
add anything
else to the conversation or what you
said has already been said
you know when you have those round
tables and everybody speak or you have
those uh those panel discussion panels
there's a question that is asked one
person on the panel says something and
then another person
says the same thing that the first
person said but slightly different
and the third person says it but
slightly different
than another person yo when the first
person that said the message
said it in a clear way it doesn't happen
just say i agree move on
to this right now i could say a whole
lot more
but because abba spoke a whole lot about
that and said what i wanted to say
i'mma end it there because i'm just
gonna be repeating what he said
in a different town you know it's funny
when celebrities speak on
certain topics a lot of people say shut
up you don't know what you're talking
about go back to dribbling or go back to
this or go back to that
right it's common isn't it especially if
you don't know what it is that you're
talking about
there's a lot of virtue signaling out
there okay
definitely a lot of people trying to say
this is who you are because you didn't
care about something i care about
but we can apply that logic to any
situation in this world
so just be mindful that listen i don't
think what's happening is good
i don't think that it's not necessarily
tragedy i don't think that there isn't
one side that's more one the other
i agree with a lot of those sentiments
but i also don't want to talk about it
that's it maybe that's not pc maybe
that's not the right thing to say
whatever i don't really care to be
honest with you
it's how i feel so i'm going to be
honest with you guys about that and if
you say i don't want to support abbott
preach unsubscribe go ahead
there's nothing wrong with that right if
you guys say i haven't preached or not
we don't have to talk about the same
topics we don't have to care about the
same things
there's plenty things i care about that
a lot of y'all don't give a [ __ ] about
and that's okay so let's not get up here
if you guys want to there's great
resources you guys can go to secular
talk you guys can go to
rising you guys can go to rt there's a
lot of different news that lets you've
done great videos on this conflict who
would be
far better set to educate you guys and
to help you understand
where you should stand than me and
preach defranco
i mean i don't know too much about him
in his news reporting but
there's options there's a lot of options
but we're not your mouthpiece
we don't have an opinion on everything
and we don't have to speak on everything
okay no we don't all right so so stop
this whole like you guys need to speak
on this if you don't this whole thing
every time something bad happens like
stop
it's cringy and it just reflects poorly
on you because you're
externalizing your own inadequacies when
i got issues and i got problems that i'm
dealing with that i think are really
important you know what i don't do i
don't go out here and tell you guys what
you should care about
i made the same top point when the black
lives matter stuff happened
remember when some people didn't post a
black square and a black folks got mad
at white people or other people who
didn't post it
yours you're not you don't support us
what good is this kind of rhetoric
so this is how i am i think now more
than ever people
people like bandages they like band-aids
on their problems
they think that if they doesn't solve
[ __ ] exactly
and it's just like i'm not here for that
so if you want me to help cool
i'll stop performing bar mitzvahs i'll
go support my local shawarma shop
eat a couple extra baklavas on ramadan
but i'm not doing all this extra stuff
so you're asking the wrong man that's
all i got so anything else you want to
say about this
no all right that free pal stuff
[Music]
deuces bomber drop
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
hold on